où
[Musique]
plongez dans un univers parallèle onirik
contemplatif tels des âmes fuyant leur
enveloppe charnelle c'est pierre
sélénites jette une pâle lueur sur des
souches dorment l'orme un arbre
quasiment disparu en europe cette oeuvre
de stéphane durand sonne comme un
hommage à la nature vulnérables c'est
vraiment une oeuvre qui incitent à la
méditation qui nous fait nous éloigner
des dures réalités de notre monde c'est
c'est vraiment on peut dire à un
chef-d'oeuvre et chaque visiteur est
transporté par cette ambiance tout à
fait particulière
la nature c'est le fil conducteur de
cette quinzième saison d'art
contemporain l'exposition nous invite à
flâner sur le domaine du château de
chaumont découvrir des oeuvres qui mêle
poésie et écologie comme ce lustre de
l'artiste américain john gred
ce sont des milliers de petits
réservoirs d'eau qui ont été faits avec
de la résine de façon très respectueuse
très écologique et qui recueille l'eau
qui nous est donnée par le ciel et c'est
une manière de saluer cette eau dans ces
périodes de réchauffement climatique et
de nous inviter à y faire attention
il faut préserver la beauté du monde
c'est très important et les artistes se
sont là pour nous passer ce message de
manière réelle et subliminale
une quinzaine de nouvelles sculptures
ont été installés voir directement créés
sur place des oeuvres qui font corps
avec l'environnement elle a utilisé une
matière qui vient du parc nous avons dû
abattre un certain nombre d'arbres qui
était abîmée par la sécheresse et puis
qui était âgé et on a utilisé ses bois
qui viennent du parc et c'est donc une
manière de ne rien perdre et de célébrer
la beauté des arbres et des branches
même quand ils sont morts
l'exposition est en place pour les six
prochains mois elle se terminera le 30
octobre
obama